same person to kill Karen and David did
this we got a psychopath living with us
we gotta find them Rick and I'm not
gonna sleep until we do hey youtubers
it's Charlie I hope you guys have all
had an awesome holiday week so far I've
been doing so many Sherlock and Doctor
Who videos that I didn't want to let New
Year's creep I without inviting walkers
to the party we just got some news that
there's going to be one more major
character death in the second half of
season 4 so I thought it'd be a lot of
fun to try and narrow down who it's
going to be to be clear this isn't
coming right away but it is coming
before the actual season finale it'll be
really hard to top the two big desk that
happened during episode 8 but it does
help us narrow down the choices just a
little bit big heads up too if you
haven't seen my game of thrones kill
this video yet I'm doing a contest to
try and guess you know each week who's
going to be dying on the show and which
order I'm gonna be doing the exact same
thing for walking dead but i'm going to
post a separate video kind of explaining
how that's going to work before the show
comes back be sure to subscribe to
participate also careful for spoilers in
this video we're gonna have to talk a
little bit about the comic books it's a
bit of a game of thrones situation where
things change from the book to the show
so here's my top five pieces of evidence
about who this next WTF death is going
to be number one who is safe let's talk
about who it's not going to be first and
that is daryl dixon everyone breathes a
sigh of relief Norman Reedus already
talked about how excited he was to get
back and start filming season 5 meaning
he is definitely returning number two
the biggest person who was not in the
comic books the biggest character who is
not in the comic books is Beth but based
on the evidence in my number for number
five points I think that she's much
lower on the potential kill list than
other characters number three who is
feeding the rats they didn't resolve the
issue of who was feeding the rats in the
prison but they're going to pick that
back up during the second half of season
for the best theory I've seen so far is
that it was Lizzie tyrese actually
theorized that the same person who is
feeding those rats killed Karen and
David and here's where Carol comes back
into the story number four Carol vs.
Tyrese Carol is coming back we don't
know which episode but we do know that
she'll be meeting up with Teresa's group
remember he ran off into the woods with
Lizzie and her friends and most likely
baby Judith too we know that no one ever
told Tyrese about Carol confessing to
killing Karen and David but what if
carol was just covering for Lizzie what
would Tyrese do if he discovered the
truth
and it turned out to be Lizzie he
probably wouldn't kill her but he would
try to get rid of her and Carol would do
anything to save Lizzie like killing
Tyreese to prevent him from hurting her
or sending her away number five it's
someone who's still alive in the comic
books it's an unconfirmed rumor but the
biggest characters in the show that are
still alive in the comic books include
Rick Karl Maggie and Michonne of all
those people the most heartbreaking
death I could imagine would be Maggie
plus there's some really strong evidence
that she's leaving the show including
the fact that lauren cohan wasn't
spotted on set when they were shooting
the second half of the coming episodes
this next year and she hasn't been very
active on Twitter lately which is very
unusual for her all these signs point to
her either dying or going on a long trip
off camera somewhere around episode 12
or 13 so the whole business with the
rats Lizzie Tyrese and Carol could be
misdirection for the death of someone
very unexpected say like Maggie so based
on that evidence here's my list of
people who I think it's going to be from
most likely to least likely starting
with Maggie Tyrese Lizzie Carol Michonne
Rick and Carl let me know based on that
evidence whether or not you think it's
going to be Maggie who's going to be the
next big character to die on the show or
if you think it's going to be someone
else next week there are actually a
couple new shows coming back including
Sherlock series 3 community season 5 and
my anime club that's starting on
Saturday so once we get past that I'll
do a video explaining how my Walking
Dead killers show is going to work be
sure to subscribe to get everything
don't forget I'm also giving away a
twenty dollar gift card to a random
subscriber in the comments to this video
even though technically it's not a who
like video if you haven't want anything
so far don't worry I'll be giving away
something once a week during anime club
too that'll be every Saturday right now
click here to get my top 10 predictions
for walking dead next year and click
here to start getting ready for Sherlock
series 3 thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tomorrow high fives
you